A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
清新的水花会涤荡你的心田。那些蔚蓝的巨浪能够推着你向前，也能带来平静与慰藉。沿着密歇根的海岸线。只需用心感受当下的流动。让那些浩瀚的湖泊、河流与溪流汇聚成永恒的记忆。纵身跃入纯净密歇根，让清新的水流洗去铅华。访问 Michigan.org 保持新鲜体验，或浏览我们的网站。
It was only 7.30 in the morning, but 35-year-old Eileen Field was already hard at work. As a stewardess on an ocean liner, her days were kept busy looking after first class passengers. More specifically, Eileen's job was to see to the needs of women staying on the B-deck of the Durban Castle. Owned by the Union Castle line, the ship was built in Belfast in 1938. When World War II broke out, it was repurposed to carry troops, but after the Allies won, it became a commercial ocean liner again. By 1947, the Durban Castle was sailing regularly from Cape Town in South Africa to the English port of Southampton, ferrying travelers between the two countries. To keep passengers occupied and entertained, there were amenities such as a salon, a shop and swimming pools on board,
当时才早上7点半，但35岁的艾琳·菲尔德（Eileen Field）已经开始忙碌地工作了。作为远洋客轮上的乘务员，她的日常工作就是照顾头等舱的乘客。具体来说，艾琳的工作是照料住在“德班城堡号”（Durban Castle）B层客舱的女性乘客的需求。这艘船由联合城堡航运公司（Union Castle Line）所有，于1938年在贝尔法斯特建造。二战爆发时，它被改装用于运送军队；但在盟军胜利后，它重新成为了一艘商业远洋客轮。到1947年，这艘“德班城堡号”定期往返于南非开普敦和英国的南安普敦港，在两国之间运送旅客。为了让乘客在船上有事可做并得到娱乐，船上配备了沙龙、商店和游泳池等设施，
as well as specially organized games, movie nights and dinner dances. As Eileen Field started work on the morning of Saturday, October 18, the ship was on the 8th day of its two-week voyage and about 90 miles off the West African coast. Eileen hurried along a corridor on Durban Castle's B-deck towards Cabin 126, which was occupied by a 21-year-old English actress named Eileen Gibson, better known by her stage name of Gay Gibson. It was Eileen's job to wake Gay and bring her some orange juice. Eileen knocked gently on Gay's door. When there was no answer, she knocked again and called out softly,
以及专门组织的各种游戏、电影之夜和晚宴舞会。10月18日星期六早晨，当艾琳·菲尔德开始工作时，这艘船已经进行了为期两周航行的第8天，距离西非海岸约90英里。“德班城堡号”的B层走廊里，艾琳急匆匆地走向126号客舱。该客舱住着一位21岁的英国女演员，名叫艾琳·2吉布森（Eileen Gibson），但她更广为人知的艺名是盖伊·吉布森（Gay Gibson）。艾琳的工作是叫醒盖伊并给她带去一些橙汁。艾琳轻轻敲了敲盖伊的房门。见里面没有回应，她又敲了敲，轻声喊道：
Miss Gibson. There was no reply. Eileen decided to try the door handle, even though she knew Gay locked it every night when she went to bed. To her surprise, the door opened. Gay's cabin was small, with a metal-framed single bed pushed against a wall and a porthole window four and a half feet above the cabin's floor. There was also a built-in wardrobe, a chest of drawers, a bedside light, and two buttons Gay could use to call for a steward or a stewardess. The first thing that caught Eileen's eye was the bed. It was dishevelled and unmade.
吉布森小姐。无人应答。艾琳决定试着转动门把手，尽管她知道盖伊每天晚上睡觉时都会把门反锁。令她惊讶的是，门竟然打开了。盖伊的客舱很小，靠墙放着一张铁架单人床，床头上方四英尺半处是一个舷窗。舱内还有一个嵌入式衣柜、一个斗柜、一盏床头灯，以及两个供盖伊呼叫男女乘务员的按钮。首先吸引艾琳注意的是那张床。床铺凌乱，没有整理。
The second was the porthole, which was wide open. Neither of these things were unusual in and of themselves, however, there was no sign of Gay. Her suitcase was open at the foot of the bed. The black silk dress she had worn to dinner the previous evening was hanging from a hook at the end of the bed. But Eileen couldn't see Gay's black silk pajamas or the yellow quilted dressing gown with the zip down the front that she wore over the top of them. Eileen assumed the young woman must have ducked out to the bathroom, still dressed in her nightclothes. Strangely though, Gay's slippers sat by the chest of drawers, along with the rest of her shoes. Eileen left the glass of orange juice on the top of the chest and left to attend to other duties.
第二个引起注意的是大开着的舷窗。不过，这两件事本身并不算寻常，然而，却不见盖伊的踪影。她的手提行李箱在床尾敞开着。前一天晚上晚餐时穿的那件黑色丝绸连衣裙挂在床头尽头的挂钩上。但艾琳看不到盖伊的黑色丝绸睡衣，也看不到她套在睡衣外面、前面有拉链的黄色绗缝晨衣。艾琳心想，这位年轻女子肯定穿着睡衣溜去洗手间了。不过奇怪的是，盖伊的拖鞋和其余的鞋子都放在斗柜旁。艾琳把那杯橙汁放在斗柜顶上，便离开去处理其他职责了。
When she returned in 20 minutes to collect the empty glass, she was surprised to find it full and exactly where she had left it. There was still no sign of Gay. And there was something else too. Looking over at the bed's rumpled sheets, Eileen noticed several small stains that were the colour of rust. The stains on Gay Gibson's bedding struck Eileen Field as very strange. In all the time she'd spent tidying the young woman's room, she'd never known her to have soiled sheets. After she left Gay's cabin for a second time, Eileen found a colleague who was responsible for the ship's bathrooms and asked if they'd seen Gay that morning. They hadn't.
20分钟后她回来收空杯子时，惊讶地发现杯子竟然是满的，而且原封不动地放在她刚才放的地方。依然不见盖伊的踪影。而且还有点不对劲。艾琳看着床上揉皱的床单，注意到上面有几处铁锈色的小斑点。盖伊·吉布森床铺上的血迹让艾琳·菲尔德感到非常奇怪。在她打扫这位年轻女子房间的整个期间里，她从未见过对方弄脏床单。在第二次离开盖伊的客舱后，艾琳找到了一位负责船上浴室的同事，问他们那天早上是否见过盖伊。他们没有。
Eileen was growing increasingly worried. She had gotten to know the young actress relatively well during the first week of the voyage. Gay was travelling alone to England in the hopes of furthering her stage career. She hadn't seemed nervous or uneasy about making such a big journey by herself. Instead, she struck Eileen as happy, upbeat and healthy, someone who was always pleasant to others and never caused any trouble. Early on during the trip, Gay had confided to Eileen that she was in love with a married man who was back in South Africa. But it was her acting career that she seemed most enthusiastic about. Eileen decided to wait a little longer before raising the alarm.
艾琳越来越担心了。在航行的第一周里，她已经和这位年轻的女演员比较熟悉了。盖伊独自一人前往英国，希望能进一步发展她的演艺生涯。对于独自踏上这么长的旅程，她似乎并没有感到紧张或不安。相反，在艾琳看来，她快乐、乐观且健康，是一个对人总是很友好、从不惹麻烦的人。在航行初期，盖伊曾向艾琳吐露，她爱上了一个留在南非的有妇之夫。但她似乎对自己的演艺事业更加充满热情。艾琳决定再等一会儿才拉响警报。
When Gay failed to show in the dining saloon for breakfast, Eileen reported her missing. A search of the ship was undertaken, but Gay wasn't found anywhere. Fearing that she may have fallen overboard, the ship's captain ordered that the vessel be turned around so the waters could be searched. A message was also broadcast over the ship's loudspeakers, asking anyone who knew where Gay might be to immediately report to the Persa. Two passengers were particularly alarmed to hear Gay was missing. Frank Hopwood, who worked as a procurement manager for the Union Castle Line and an RAF squadron leader named William Bray, were both in their mid-40s and travelling solo. The two men shared the same dining table that Gay was assigned to and had befriended her over the past week. Because Gay was a young woman travelling alone, they saw it as their responsibility to look out for her.
当盖伊没有出现在餐厅吃早餐时，艾琳报告她失踪了。船上展开了搜寻，但到处都找不到盖伊。由于担心她可能失足落水，船长下令调转船头以便搜寻海域。船上的扬声器还广播了一条消息，要求任何知道盖伊可能在哪里的人立即向帕萨（Persa）报告。有两名乘客听到盖伊失踪的消息时特别惊慌。弗兰克·霍普伍德（Frank Hopwood）是联合城堡航运公司的一名采购经理，另一位是皇家空军中队长威廉·布雷（William Bray），两人都在40岁左右，独自出行。这两名男子和盖伊被分配在同一张餐桌上，过去一周里与她结下了友谊。由于盖伊是一位独自旅行的年轻女性，他们认为照顾她是自己的责任。
Gay had mentioned how she had heart trouble that prevented her from playing the deck games other passengers took part in. Frank also thought she seemed sad and tired at times. The previous night, Frank and William had escorted Gay to one of the ship's dinner dances. With just 250 passengers, the ship was less than a third full, and Gay was the youngest on board. Most of the others in first class were aged in their 40s or above. The 21-year-old Gay attracted a lot of attention in her black evening gown, silver shoes, and urban hair worn in a stylish bob. Lots of men asked to dance with her throughout the evening. After leaving the dance, Gay sat with Frank and William in the first class smoke room until it closed.
盖伊曾提到，她的心脏有问题，这使她无法参加其他乘客参与的甲板游戏。有时，弗兰克也觉得她看起来悲伤而疲惫。前一天晚上，弗兰克和威廉曾护送盖伊参加船上的晚宴舞会之一。船上只有250名乘客，客座率不到三分之一，盖伊是船上最年轻的乘客。头等舱的其他大多数人都在40岁或以上。21岁的盖伊穿着黑色晚礼服、银色鞋子，留着时髦的齐耳短发，吸引了大量目光。整个晚上，许多人都邀请她跳舞。离开舞会后，盖伊和弗兰克、威廉一起坐在头等舱吸烟室，直到它关门。
It was a warm night as the ship sailed along the West African coast, so Gay decided to have a swim in one of the pools. She went to her cabin to fetch her bathing suit, but couldn't find it. Disappointed, she rejoined Frank and William on the deck and the trio chatted until 12.40am. Then Frank escorted Gay to her cabin, wishing her a good night and sweet dreams before departing. Her failure to appear at breakfast that morning worried both men. When they heard the loudspeaker announcement, their concern only grew. The captain also radioed other ships in the vicinity, notifying them that a woman was believed to have gone overboard on the Durban Castle and asking that they keep a lookout for her. The ship was steered back and crew members spent about an hour searching the waters for any sign of Gay.
由于船正沿着西非海岸航行，那天晚上很温暖，于是盖伊决定去其中一个泳池游泳。她回客舱拿泳衣，但没有找到。她很失望，重新回到甲板上找弗兰克和威廉，三人一直聊到凌晨12点40分。随后，弗兰克护送盖伊回到她的客舱，在离开前祝她晚安、做个好梦。那天早上她没有出现在早餐桌上，这让两名男子感到担忧。听到广播里的公告时，他们的担忧有增无减。船长还通过无线电联系了附近的船只，通知他们“德班城堡号”上有一名女子被认为落水了，并要求他们留意她的踪迹。船被调转方向，船员们花了大约一个小时在海面上搜寻盖伊的踪迹。
They found nothing. Captain Arthur Pady knew that even if Gay had still been alive when she went overboard, she couldn't survive in the North Atlantic Ocean for that long. The water was freezing and home to enormous sharks. The elderly woman who occupied the cabin next door to Gay's was asked if she had heard anything suspicious the night before. She said she'd been woken in the middle of the night by a crashing sound right outside her door, as though a metal tray had fallen to the ground. But she never heard any voices. It occurred to Captain Pady that perhaps Gay hadn't fallen overboard at all. Maybe she had been the victim of a crime.
他们什么也没找到。亚瑟·帕迪（Arthur Pady）船长知道，即使盖伊落水时还活着，她也不可能在北大西洋生存那么长时间。海水冰冷刺骨，而且栖息着巨大的鲨鱼。住在盖伊隔壁客舱的那位老妇人被问及前一天晚上是否听到任何可疑的声音。她说自己半夜被门外的一声巨响吵醒了，听起来就像是一个金属托盘掉到了地上。但她从未听到任何声音。帕迪船长突然想到，也许盖伊根本没有落水。也许她成了某种犯罪的受害者。
He ordered her cabin locked and set the ship back on course before beginning a rudimentary investigation. One by one, passengers and crew members were summoned to his office to share what they knew about the situation. Frank Hopwood and William Bray explained how Gay had retired to her cabin at around 12.40am, but a Boson's mate reported seeing her about 20 minutes later. He had been supervising the swabbing of the decks and noticed Gay standing by a rail smoking a cigarette and still wearing her evening gown. He warned her that her feet could get wet if she stayed where she was, so she moved along. That hadn't been the last time Gay was sighted. A 39-year-old night watchman named Fred Steer had been on duty the previous night. At around 3am, he was busy in the first-class pantry when he heard bells ringing for assistance.
他下令锁上她的客舱，并将船调回航向，随后开始了一场初步调查。乘客和船员被一个接一个地传唤到他的办公室，分享他们所了解的情况。弗兰克·霍普伍德和威廉·布雷解释了盖伊是如何在大约凌晨12点40分回客舱休息的，但一名水头长（Boson's mate）报告说，大约20分钟后看到过她。当时他正在监督甲板冲洗工作，注意到盖伊正靠在栏杆边抽烟，身上仍然穿着晚礼服。他警告她，如果一直待在原地，鞋子会被弄湿，于是她便走开了。那并不是最后一次有人看到盖伊。一个名叫弗雷德·斯蒂尔（Fred Steer）的39岁夜间巡夜员前一天晚上当班。凌晨3点左右，他正在头等舱的食品储藏室里忙碌，突然听到求助的铃声响起。
Upon investigating, he saw that both the red and green lights were flashing. This indicated that a passenger had pressed two buttons in their cabin. One to summon a steward and another for a stewardess. Fred was baffled. Usually, a passenger called for just one crew member. Requesting two was highly unusual. Fred walked along the portside corridor looking to see which cabin the lights were coming from. He followed them to cabin 126, Gay Gibson's cabin.
经查看，他看到红灯和绿灯都在闪烁。这表明有乘客在客舱里按下了两个按钮。一个用于呼叫男服务员，另一个用于呼叫女服务员。弗雷德感到大惑不解。通常情况下，乘客只呼叫一名乘务员。要求两名是非常罕见的。弗雷德沿着左舷走廊走去，查看这些灯光来自哪个客舱。他一路追踪到了126号客舱，即盖伊·吉布森的客舱。
It was located at the end of a small alleyway. This section of the ship was sparsely occupied. A woman in her 70s was staying in the cabin next to Gay's, but the other neighbouring rooms were empty. Fred knocked on the door of Gay's cabin. There was no response, so he carefully tried opening it. The door swung inwards, which was strange. Gay always made a point of locking it when she went to bed. It had opened about two inches wide when Fred heard a man's voice say,
它位于一条小巷的尽头。这部分的船舱入住率很低。一位70多岁的妇人住在盖伊隔壁的客舱，但其他相邻的房间都是空的。弗雷德敲了敲盖伊客舱的门。无人回应，于是他小心翼翼地试着推开它。门向内敞开，这很奇怪。盖伊每次睡觉时都会特意把它锁上。门大约打开了两英寸宽，这时弗雷德听到一个男人的声音说：
It's alright. Then the door slammed closed. But not before Fred caught a glimpse of someone inside. A black haired man had been standing in the darkness facing the door. Fred recognised him right away. 30-year-old Dex Stuart James Cam had a reputation as a ladies man. Some of the other crew members nicknamed him Don Jimmy as a play on the name of the infamous womaniser Don Juan. Although Cam had a wife and young daughter back in England,
没关系。接着门“砰”的一声关上了。不过，就在门关上之前，弗雷德瞥见了里面的一个人。一个黑发男子正站在黑暗中面对着门。弗雷德一眼就认出了他。30岁的德克斯·斯图亚特·詹姆斯·卡姆（Dex Stuart James Cam）素有花花公子的名声。其他一些船员给他取了个绰号叫“唐·吉米”（Don Jimmy），这是对臭名昭著的好色之徒唐·璜（Don Juan）名字的戏称。尽管卡姆在英国有一个妻子和一个年幼的女儿，
that didn't prevent him from taking a keen interest in the women he served as passengers. Described as handsome and charming, Cam had served in the Merchant Navy Reserve during World War II, then joined the Union Castle fleet in 1946. He liked the easy tasks of being a Dex Stuart. His roles included organising games for passengers and serving them food and drinks. Tips were easy to come by, and the manual labour was minimal. Multiple crew members had reported seeing Cam take an interest in Gay Gibson. Now, Fred Steer was reporting that he'd seen Cam in Gay's cabin at 3am the night she vanished.
但这并没有阻止他对作为乘客的女宾客表现出浓厚的兴趣。卡姆被描述为英俊迷人，他在二战期间曾在商船预备役服役，随后于1946年加入了联合城堡船队。他喜欢甲板服务员（Dex Stuart）轻松的工作。他的职责包括为乘客组织游戏以及为他们提供食物和饮料。小费很容易拿到，体力劳动也很少。多名船员曾报告说看到卡姆对盖伊·吉布森产生了兴趣。现在，弗雷德·斯蒂尔报告说，在盖伊失踪当晚的凌晨3点，他曾在盖伊的客舱里看到过卡姆。
Dex Stuart's were not permitted to enter passengers' rooms at any time, let alone in the middle of the night. After seeing Cam slam Gay's door shut, Fred hurried back to the pantry and told his superior what had happened. The two men walked over to Gay's cabin together and stood outside for about five minutes, listening quietly. They heard nothing, and there was no sign of Cam. Ultimately, it was decided that it wasn't their place to interfere with the passengers' private life, and the matter was left alone. Upon learning this information, Captain Pady knew that he had to speak with James Cam immediately. When Cam arrived at the captain's office, Pady wasted no time in asking him, Do you know why this first-class passenger is missing Cam?
甲板服务员在任何时间都不被允许进入乘客的房间，更不用说在半夜了。看到卡姆“砰”地关上盖伊的房门后，弗雷德匆忙跑回储藏室，把发生的事情告诉了他的上司。两名男子一起走到盖伊的客舱外，在外面站了大约五分钟，静静地听着。他们什么也没听到，也没有看到卡姆的踪迹。最终，他们认为干涉乘客的私生活不是他们的职责，此事便不了了之。得知这一信息后，帕迪船长知道他必须立刻与詹姆斯·卡姆谈谈。当卡姆到达船长办公室时，帕迪毫不浪费时间地质问他：“卡姆，你知道为什么这位头等舱乘客失踪了吗？”
No, sir, Cam replied. Captain Pady kept Fred Steer's sighting to himself, but informed Cam that he was suspected of being near Gay Gibson's cabin. Cam adamantly denied this, stating, I know the rules, and I obey them. He had gone to bed at 12.45 and didn't leave his room until it was time to get up for work in the morning. Cam did acknowledge that he'd gotten to know Gay quite well over the first week of the voyage. The pair had chatted from time to time, and Cam said that Gay seemed to show, quote, a preference for my services by asking him to deliver drinks to her cabin on several occasions. Two nights earlier, he'd sent a tray with a large glass of rum to her room, but he later noticed that she hadn't touched it.
“不知道，长官，”卡姆回答道。帕迪船长把弗雷德·斯蒂尔看到的情况藏在心里，但通知卡姆，他被怀疑曾在盖伊·吉布森的客舱附近出没。卡姆坚决否认，声称：“我知道规矩，我也遵守规矩。”他在12点45分就上床睡觉了，直到早上该起床上班时才离开房间。卡姆确实承认，在航行的第一周里，他与盖伊变得相当熟悉。两人时常聊天，卡姆说盖伊似乎表现出“对我的服务的偏爱”，曾多次要求他将饮料送到她的客舱。两天前的晚上，他曾送去一个放有大杯朗姆酒的托盘到她的房间，但他后来注意到她根本没有动过。
The next day, he ran into her and teased her about not drinking the rum, saying, I have a bone to pick with you, and a big one at that. Somewhat reassured that Cam might be telling the truth, Captain Pady asked if he had any reason to believe that Gay might be depressed beneath her outwardly upbeat exterior. Cam paused, before telling the captain how Gay had mentioned she was in love with a married man back in Johannesburg, quote, she said she was crazy about him and complications had set in. I asked her real free like, I told you she was friendly towards me, what she meant. She said she suspected she might be going to have a baby. This was not the first time Cam had spoken to a colleague about Gay Gibson being pregnant. Stewardess Eileen Field had encountered him in the pantry several days before the young actress disappeared.
第二天，他偶遇了她，并拿她没喝朗姆酒的事开玩笑说：“我和你有点账要算，而且是一笔大账。”帕迪船长感到卡姆可能在说实话，这让他稍微放心了一些，于是追问对方是否有理由相信盖伊在表面上的乐观外表下可能会感到沮丧。卡姆停顿了一下，然后告诉船长盖伊曾提到她爱上了约翰内斯堡的一位有妇之夫，“她说她疯狂地爱着他，而且情况变得复杂了。我很随性地问她——我跟你说过她对我很友好——她是什么意思。她说她怀疑自己可能要生孩子了。”这并不是卡姆第一次向同事谈及盖伊·吉布森怀孕的事。乘务员艾琳·菲尔德在年轻女演员失踪前几天曾在储藏室里遇到过他。
As Eileen handed over a tea tray that she had just collected from Gay's cabin, Cam said, Miss Gibson is three months pregnant by a married man. Eileen, who didn't believe this for a second, told Cam off for spreading rumors about a female passenger. He replied that Gay had told him that herself. Eileen had strong suspicions that Cam had taken an interest in Gay. On one occasion, Eileen found Cam on B-deck, the area where Gay's cabin was and where Deck Stewards were not permitted to be. When he commented that Gay hadn't had her tea that day, Eileen responded, If I find you in the vicinity of Miss Gibson's cabin, I will report you to the Chief Steward.
当时艾琳正递上她刚从盖伊客舱收来的茶盘，卡姆说道：“吉布森小姐怀了一个有妇之夫的孩子，已经三个月了。”艾琳根本不相信这话，她训斥卡姆到处散布关于女乘客的谣言。他则回答说是盖伊亲口告诉他的。艾琳强烈怀疑卡姆对盖伊产生了兴趣。有一次，艾琳在B层发现了卡姆，这个区域正是盖伊的客舱所在地，而甲板服务员是不允许出现在那里的。当卡姆评论说盖伊那天没喝茶时，艾琳回应道：“如果我发现你在吉布森小姐的客舱附近出没，我会向总乘务长举报你。”
One morning, Eileen collected a tray from Gay's room and saw there were two used tea cups. She had no idea who the second cup belonged to. Based on witness accounts, it was clear something had happened to Gay in the very early morning, between the time her cabin's call buttons were pressed at 3am to when Eileen Field attended her cabin at 7.30am. When Captain Pady spoke to James Cam's cabin mate, he disagreed with a crucial detail in Cam's version of events. Cam had claimed he was in bed by 12.45am, but his fellow crew member had retired at 1am and Cam was nowhere to be seen. When he was told about this discrepancy, Cam changed his story. He'd been working until one o'clock and then he went out to a deck where he sat and smoked for a while.
一天早晨，艾琳从盖伊的房间收回一个茶盘，看到里面有两个用过的茶杯。她根本不知道第二个茶杯是谁的。根据目击者的陈述，很显然，盖伊在清晨极早的时候发生了一些事情——介于凌晨3点客舱呼叫按钮被按下到早上7点30分艾琳·菲尔德前往她的客舱之间。当帕迪船长找詹姆斯·卡姆的同舱室友谈话时，对方反驳了卡姆版本中的一个关键细节。卡姆曾声称自己在凌晨12点45分就已经躺在床上了，但他的同舱船员是在凌晨1点才去休息的，当时卡姆根本不见踪影。当被告知这一出入时，卡姆改了口。他一直工作到一点钟，然后出去到一个甲板上坐着抽了一会儿烟。
He dosed off and when he woke, he went to bed properly. By that time, it was about 2am. Despite Cam's firm denials, Captain Pady informed him that he was a suspect in Gay's disappearance and would have to be examined by the ship's doctor as a matter of protocol. Cam agreed. The doctor had Cam remove his clothes. He didn't have any bruises or strange marks, but the doctor did notice some light scratches on his left shoulder and wrist. These looked old as though they'd been there for a few days. Cam explained that he'd scratched himself due to the humid tropical weather.
他打了个盹，醒来后才真正去睡觉。当时大约是凌晨2点。尽管卡姆坚决否认，帕迪船长还是通知他，他是盖伊失踪案的嫌疑人，作为惯例，必须接受船医的检查。卡姆同意了。医生让卡姆脱掉衣服。他身上没有任何淤青或奇怪的印记，但医生确实注意到他左肩和手腕上有一些轻微的划痕。这些划痕看起来很旧，好像已经存在好几天了。卡姆解释说，是因为湿热的热带天气导致他自己抓挠的。
However, on the back of Cam's neck and on his right forearm were more scratches. The ones on his neck were very thin. They didn't look like the work of human fingernails. They looked more like scratches made by a cat. Cam said they had been left by a particularly rough towel he'd used to dry himself. The wounds on Cam's arm looked the most suspicious. There were about 12 of them, all about half an inch long and very fresh looking. Cam claimed that these two were caused by him scratching himself, but to the doctor they looked, quote, suggestive of violence. Police in England were notified of Gay's disappearance and detectives from Scotland Yard made preparations to board the ship as it approached the UK.
然而，在卡姆的后颈和右前臂上还有更多的划痕。他脖子上的那些非常细。它们看起来不像是人类指甲造成的。看起来更像是猫抓的痕迹。卡姆说，那是他用来擦干身体的一条质地特别粗糙的毛巾留下的。卡姆手臂上的伤口看起来最可疑。大约有12处，每一处都有半英寸长左右，而且看起来非常新鲜。卡姆声称这些也是他自己抓痒造成的，但在医生看来，它们看起来“带有暴力的暗示”。英国警方已接到盖伊失踪的通知，苏格兰场的侦探们在船只接近英国时做好了登船准备。
In the meantime, James Cam resumed his duties. Gay Gibson's cabin was deemed a crime scene. Its porthole was closed and the door padlocked to preserve any evidence inside. Exactly one week after Gay went missing, the Durban Castle anchored off the Isle of Wight and two detectives from Scotland Yard boarded. They made their way to cabin 126 to inspect Gay's last known location. Her belongings lay scattered throughout, including her hairbrush and a book she had been reading. Five letters of introduction to British theatres and acting agents were discovered stashed in a small leather bag. In Gay's suitcase, detectives found a tube of spermacidal jelly and a diaphragm which was unused. These two items are used by women as a means to prevent pregnancy.
与此同时，詹姆斯·卡姆恢复了他的工作。盖伊·吉布森的客舱被认定为犯罪现场。其舷窗被关闭，房门被加锁以保护里面的任何证据。在盖伊失踪整整一周后，“德班城堡号”在怀特岛外锚泊，两名来自苏格兰场的侦探登上了船。他们径直走向126号客舱，以检查盖伊最后为人所知的地方。她的随身物品散落各处，包括她的发刷和她一直在读的一书。在一个小皮包里发现了五封介绍信，对象是英国的剧院和演艺经纪人。在盖伊的行李箱里，侦探们发现了一管杀精凝胶和一个未使用的子宫帽（避孕隔膜）。这两样东西是女性用来作为避孕手段的。
Once the ship arrived at Southampton, the cabin was dusted for prints. A palm print was discovered on the back of the door. An examination of the porthole revealed tiny wisps of fabric around its edges. Gay's bedding was removed so the stains could be forensically tested. Investigators found urine on the sheets, as well as typo blood. James Cam was immediately escorted to Southampton Police Headquarters for a formal interview. For the past week, he'd been maintaining the same story. He'd become friendly with Gay while serving her on board, but he hadn't been to her cabin since the beginning of the trip. After his crewmates reminded him, he wasn't permitted to attend to passengers in their rooms.
船一抵达南安普敦，警方就在客舱里采集了指纹。门背后发现了一个掌纹。对舷窗的检查在边缘发现了极细的纤维碎屑。盖伊的床铺被取走，以便对血迹进行法医检测。调查人员在床单上发现了尿液，以及B型血。詹姆斯·卡姆立即被押送至南安普敦警察局接受正式讯问。在过去的一周里，他一直坚持同一种说法。他在船上服务盖伊时与她变得熟络，但自航行开始以来，他就没有去过她的客舱。在同伴提醒他之后，他才知道自己不被允许去乘客的房间服务。
Cam was left to wait in an interrogation room for almost 12 hours. Detectives hoped that the time alone would make him anxious and more inclined to confess. But when they finally went in to speak with him, he continued to deny knowing anything about what happened to Gay. Finally, after more than an hour of back and forth, a detective remarked, I don't want to go through all your movements again. Based on our inquiries, I have now established you were in Miss Gibson's cabin that night. At that moment, Cam realized that Fred Steer must have recognized him when he opened the cabin door and identified him to investigators. Then, he asked a strange question.
卡姆被留在一个审讯室里等待了近12个小时。侦探们希望单独呆着的时间会让他感到焦虑，从而更倾向于招供。但当他们最终进去跟他谈话时，他依然否认知道任何关于盖伊遭遇的事。最后，经过一个多小时的来回拉扯，一名侦探评论道：“我不想再重复你所有的行动轨迹了。根据我们的调查，我现已确定那天晚上你在吉布森小姐的客舱里。”那一刻，卡姆意识到，当他打开客舱门时，弗雷德·斯蒂尔一定认出了他，并向调查人员指认了他。接着，他问了一个奇怪的问题。
Does this mean I murdered her? Will I be charged with murder? Cam was informed that it would entirely depend on the circumstances involved with his interviewing detective stating, You may be able to give a reasonable explanation of the cause of her death, and we will give great consideration to what you say. There was a long silence. Then, Cam looked directly at the detective and said, I want to tell you something. At 11 on the night of Friday, October 17, Cam decided to ask Gay if she wanted some lemonade with her glass of rum that evening. He found her in her cabin, searching for her bathing suit. He knew he shouldn't be there, but he approached her anyway.
“这是否意味着我谋杀了她？我会以谋杀罪被起诉吗？”卡姆被告知，这完全取决于与他面谈的审探所涉及的情节，审讯侦探表示：“你也许能对她死因的原因给出一个合理的解释，我们会对你所说的话给予充分的考虑。”长久的沉默。然后，卡姆直视着侦探说：“我想告诉你一件事。”在10月17日星期五的晚上11点，卡姆决定问盖伊那天晚上她的朗姆酒是否需要加点柠檬水。他在客舱里找到了她，当时她正在找泳衣。他知道自己不应该在那里，但还是向她走了过去。
He asked Gay if she'd like some lemonade that night, but she declined. Then, Cam asked, Do you know what? I've got a good mind to get a drink and join you later. Please yourself, said Gay. Then, she went back upstairs to rejoin her friends. As Cam described it, the two had essentially organized the date. Cam left the rum outside Gay's cabin. He returned at around 1am and knocked on the door. There was no answer. He left and went back again an hour later. This time, Gay answered his knock by inviting him to come in. Cam stepped into the cabin, closing the door behind him, but leaving it unlocked.
他问盖伊那天晚上是否想要点柠檬水，但她拒绝了。接着，卡姆问道：“你知道吗？我挺想拿杯饮料随后去找你的。”“随你的便，”盖伊说。然后，她回到楼上与朋友们重新会合。正如卡姆所描述的那样，两人基本上算是约好了。卡姆把朗姆酒留在了盖伊的客舱外。他在凌晨1点左右返回并敲了门。无人应答。他离开并在一个小时后再次折返。这一次，盖伊应声邀请他进去。卡姆走进客舱，反手关上门，但没有锁上。
Gay was lying in bed, wearing her yellow quilted dressing gown. The two began to chat. Then, Cam climbed into the single bed alongside Gay. Cam told the investigators that the two started having sex with Gay's consent. Suddenly, Gay clutched at Cam and froze. Seconds later, her body fell entirely limp. Her eyes glazed over and there was froth dotted with specks of blood in the corners of her mouth. Terrified, Cam leapt out of bed. It looked to him as though Gay had fainted. He began trying to resuscitate her to no avail. Gay remained lifeless.
盖伊正躺在床上，穿着她那件黄色的绗缝晨衣。两人开始闲聊起来。接着，卡姆钻进了盖伊身旁的单人床。卡姆告诉调查人员，在盖伊的同意下，两人开始发生性关系。突然，盖伊紧紧抓住卡姆，僵住了。几秒钟后，她的身体完全瘫软下来。她的双眼变得呆滞，嘴角泛起带有血丝的泡沫。卡姆吓坏了，从床上跳了下来。在他看来，盖伊好像晕倒了。他开始试图对她进行心肺复苏，但无济于事。盖伊依然毫无生气。
Then, there was a knock at the door. It was Fred's steer, responding to the call for a steward and stewardess. Cam had no idea how the call buttons came to be switched on. He hadn't pressed them and he didn't think Gay had either, accidentally or otherwise. Cam slammed the door in Fred's face, then bolted it. Now, he was panicking. Somehow, Gay had accidentally died during intercourse and he would be in trouble when she was found. His only thought was that he had to get rid of her body. Cam yanked open the porthole and lifted Gay, who was still wearing her dressing gown, then pushed her out of the 42-centimeter diameter opening. She fell 25 feet into the Atlantic Ocean below. Then, Cam quietly let himself out of the cabin and crept off to his own bed. Detectives didn't believe James Cam's story for a second.
这时，门外传来了敲门声。那是弗雷德·斯蒂尔，他对呼叫男男女女乘务员的要求作出的回应。卡姆根本不知道呼叫按钮是怎么被按响的。他没有按过，他也认为盖伊没有按过，无论是无意还是其他原因。卡姆当着弗雷德的面“砰”地关上门，然后将门栓死。现在，他慌了神。不知怎么的，盖伊在性爱过程中意外死亡了，等被人发现时他会惹上麻烦。他唯一的念头就是必须摆脱她的尸体。卡姆猛地拉开舷窗，抱起依然穿着晨衣的盖伊，然后将她推出了直径42厘米的开口。她坠落了25英尺，落入下方的北大西洋。接着，卡姆悄悄地走出客舱，蹑手蹑脚地回到自己的床上。侦探们对詹姆斯·卡姆的说法半个字也不信。
They were certain he had assaulted and strangled Gay Gibson, then callously disposed of her to cover up his crimes. Despite having no body, they made the decision to charge Cam with murder. When informed of the charges against him, he exclaimed, My God, I didn't think it would be as serious as this. Detective Constable Minden Plumlee was later asked to have Cam sign the official type-written version of his statement. He paid a visit to Cam in the cell where he was being held and came back with a shocking story. Apparently, Cam had made a second, more damning confession following some slight prompting. According to Plumlee, Cam told him he often visited the cabins of female passengers and said they welcomed the attention.
他们确信他袭击并勒死了盖伊·吉布森，然后冷酷无情地处理掉了她的尸体以掩盖他的罪行。尽管没有尸体，他们还是做出了指控卡姆谋杀的决定。当被告知针对他的指控时，他惊呼道：“我的天啊，我没想到事情会这么严重。”侦探警员明登·普拉姆利（Minden Plumlee）后来被要求让卡姆在打印好的官方口供文本上签名。他拜访了被关押在牢房里的卡姆，回来时带了一个令人震惊的故事。显然，在一些轻微的暗示下，卡姆作出了第二次、更具罪证力的供述。据普拉姆利称，卡姆告诉他，他经常光顾女乘客的客舱，并称她们很欢迎这种关注。
He also admitted to strangling Gay, then added that when he pushed her through the porthole, she made a hell of a splash. Detectives began building their case for trial. The palm print recovered from Gay's cavern door was confirmed to belong to James Cam, but this meant little in the way of forensic evidence as he had admitted to entering her room on multiple occasions. The blood found on Gay's sheets was presumed to be hers, as it was a different type to Cam's. The best evidence they had was the statement from Cam himself. Although he was denying murder, he was a proven liar who only admitted to being in Gay's room on the night in question when he realized a witness had identified him. Detectives were confident that a jury would agree with them and convict Cam.
他还承认勒死了盖伊，并补充说，当他把她从舷窗推出去时，“她扑通一声溅起了好大的水花。”侦探们开始为审判建立案件。从盖伊客舱门上提取到的掌纹经证实属于詹姆斯·卡姆，但这在法医证据方面意义不大，因为他已经承认曾多次进入她的房间。在盖伊床单上发现的血液被认为属于她本人，因为它的血型与卡姆的不同。他们拥有的最好证据是卡姆本人的供词。尽管他否认谋杀，但他是一个被证实了的撒谎者，直到意识到有目击者认出他后，才承认在案发当晚去过盖伊的房间。侦探们坚信陪审团会同意他们的看法并给卡姆定罪。
The courts moved quickly. Within a month, Cam's committal hearing had already taken place and he was ordered to stand trial for the murder of Gay Gibson. Cam's defence attorney was Joshua Caswell, a renowned legal mind who had successfully defended dozens of clients. Caswell was horrified by Cam's decision to throw a young woman's body out into the open sea, but was inclined to believe his client was innocent of murder. If Cam had intended to assault and kill Gay, then why hadn't he locked the cavern door behind him? When the night watchman was summoned, he was able to push the door open. Cam had slammed it shut in response and only then did he lock it.
法院的审理进展迅速。不到一个月的时间里，卡姆的移交审判就已经举行，他被命令为谋杀盖伊·吉布森接受审判。卡姆的辩护律师是约书亚·卡斯韦尔（Joshua Caswell），他是一位著名的法律界人士，曾成功为数十名客户辩护。卡斯韦尔对卡姆将一个年轻女子的尸体扔进公海的决定感到震惊，但倾向于相信他的客户没有犯谋杀罪。如果卡姆原本打算袭击并杀死盖伊，那么他为什么不在身后锁上客舱门呢？当夜间巡夜员被召唤时，他能够推开房门。卡姆因此“砰”地一声关上了门，直到那时他才将其反锁。
There were also significant doubts that Cam's second confession to Detective Constable Minden Plumlee had ever been made. It turned out that the detective had a history of using dubious methods to obtain confessions from suspects. Plumlee was also suspected of leaking information about the case to the media. He quit the police force in January 1948, just a couple of months after working the Gay Gibson case, though he denied his resignation was in any way related to that investigation. In order to defend his client, Joshua Caswell decided he would need to look at Gay Gibson's life more closely. During World War II, Gay Gibson enlisted in the female section of the British Army and performed with an acting troupe that staged shows for soldiers. She continued to pursue her acting ambitions after the war, receiving both major and minor roles in various plays.
人们也对卡姆是否真的向侦探警员明登·普拉姆利作出了第二次供述产生了重大怀疑。事实证明，这位侦探有使用可疑手段从嫌疑人那里获取口供的历史。普拉姆利还被怀疑向媒体泄露了有关此案的信息。他在1948年1月辞去了警察职务，就在处理盖伊·吉布森案几个月后，尽管他否认辞职与该调查有任何关系。为了替客户辩护，约书亚·卡斯韦尔决定需要更仔细地审视盖伊·吉布森的生活。二战期间，盖伊·吉布森应征入伍加入了英国军队的女子部队，并随一个演员工会四处演出，为士兵们呈献节目。战后她继续追求演艺梦想，在各种戏剧中获得过主角和配角。
When her father relocated to Cape Town for work, Gay and her mother decided to join him. Gay arrived in South Africa in March 1947, but soon left Cape Town for Johannesburg, as there were more acting opportunities there. By July, she had been given the lead female role in a play called Golden Boy. During the weeks and months she spent rehearsing and performing, she came to know some of her fellow cast members very well. James Cam's defence team were eager to find out more about Gay's life in Johannesburg, so they travelled to South Africa to interview people who had known her. Doreen Mantle was a young actress who shared a dressing room with Gay during Golden Boy's run. She told Cam's attorneys that Gay had been friendly and kind, but somewhat sickly. She'd seen Gay faint during rehearsals. The skin around her mouth had turned blue, and saliva had collected in the corners of her lips.
当她的父亲因工作搬到开普敦时，盖伊和母亲决定去与他团聚。盖伊于1947年3月抵达南非，但很快离开开普敦前往约翰内斯堡，因为那里的演艺机会更多。到7月份，她在一部名为《金童》（Golden Boy）的戏剧中获得了女性主角。在她排练和演出的数周和数月里，她与同剧组的一些演员变得非常熟悉。詹姆斯·卡姆的辩护团队急于了解更多关于盖伊在约翰内斯堡的生活，于是他们前往南非采访认识她的人。多琳·曼特尔（Doreen Mantle）是一位年轻女演员，在《金童》演出期间与盖伊共用一个化妆间。她告诉卡姆的律师，盖伊为人友好善良，但身体有些虚弱。她曾看到盖伊在排练时晕倒。她嘴唇周围的皮肤变蓝了，唾液聚集在嘴角。
Other witnesses said they had seen similar things. Gay had fainted at a party, in a car, and while out in public. She was perceived as physically weak, and at times those involved in the production had been worried that she wouldn't be able to perform. One actor and the play's producer said she'd told them that she had a chest complaint and suffered from asthma. Cold weather was particularly problematic for her. Some also described Gay as neurotic, highly strong, and prone to emotional outbursts. Sometime in August, Gay spoke with a doctor who was the wife of the play's producer, telling her that her period was two weeks late. The doctor reassured her that this didn't mean she was pregnant, and suggested she started using a diaphragm if she was sexually active. Doreen Mantle claimed that Gay had been romantically involved with a fellow actor named Mike Abel, who was married. She'd seen the two arguing at a cast party, and said Gay had accused Mike of getting her pregnant.
其他证人也表示看到过类似的事情。盖伊曾在派对上、车里以及在公共场合晕倒。她被认为身体虚弱，有时剧组相关人员会担心她无法完成演出。一位男演员和该剧的制片人表示，她曾告诉他们她有胸部疾病并患有哮喘。寒冷的天气对她来说尤其成问题。一些人还形容盖伊神经质、高度紧张，且容易情绪爆发。大约在8月份，盖伊咨询了一位身为该剧制片人妻子的医生，告诉她月经推迟了两周。医生向她保证这并不意味着怀孕，并建议如果她有性生活的话，可以开始使用子宫帽。多琳·曼特尔声称盖伊与一位名叫迈克·阿贝尔（Mike Abel）的已婚男演员有恋情。她曾在一次剧组派对上看到两人争吵，并称盖伊指责迈克让她怀了孕。
Mike told a different story. He said that he and Gay were just friends. She had confided in him that she was pregnant, and asked for money so she could travel to England for an abortion, but he couldn't afford to help her. When he asked who the father was, Gay just laughed. The truth of their relationship is unknown. By the end of the month, Gay had fallen in love with a 33-year-old man named Charles Shventowski, whose wife was back in England. He doted on Gay, sending her flowers and buying her clothes. After the season of Golden Boy concluded in September, the cast and crew were preparing to take the show to another city when something unexpected happened. Gay wanted to cancel her contract so she could travel back to England and chase her acting dreams on a bigger stage.
迈克则讲了另一个版本。他说他和盖伊只是朋友。她曾向他倾诉自己怀孕了，并借钱以便去英国做人工流产，但他无力资助她。当他问谁是孩子的父亲时，盖伊只是笑了笑。他们关系的真相不得而知。到了月底，盖伊爱上了一个名叫查尔斯·施文托斯基（Charles Shventowski）的33岁男子，他的妻子还在英国。他对盖伊百般呵护，送她鲜花并为她买衣服。9月份《金童》的演出季结束后，剧组正准备将该剧带到另一个城市时，发生了意想不到的事情。盖伊想要取消合同，以便回英国并在更大的舞台上追逐她的演艺梦想。
Charles paid for Gay's ticket home on the Durban Castle, and she left for Southampton within a matter of weeks. Some have speculated that Gay's abrupt departure wasn't motivated by a career move, but an unplanned pregnancy. It's been suggested that she needed to get back to England to have an abortion. But the letters of introduction found amongst her belongings do point to Gay looking to further her acting dreams upon arriving in the UK. In addition to the South African witnesses, the defence found people who said Gay had been unwell during her time in the armed forces. On one occasion, she was found lying in bed, her back arched as she clutched her chest and gasped for air. Her tongue was caught at the back of her throat. A junior officer assisted Gay by tilting her head forward and an ambulance was called.
查尔斯为盖伊支付了搭乘“德班城堡号”回家的船票，她在几周内就动身前往南非的南安普敦。有人推测盖伊的突然离开不是出于职业发展，而是因为意外怀孕。有人认为她需要回英国去做人工流产。但她在随身物品中找到的介绍信确实表明盖伊在抵达英国后希望进一步追求自己的演艺梦想。除了南非的证人外，辩护方还找到了其他人，他们称盖伊在军队服役期间身体一直不好。有一次，她被发现躺在床上，背部弓起，双手紧抓胸口，大口喘着粗气。她的舌头卡在了喉咙后部。一名初级军官通过将盖伊的头部向前倾斜来协助她，并叫了救护车。
Gay later explained to the officer that she'd had another turn. Joshua Caswell was building a theory. Gay Gibson had suffered from some sort of heart condition that had caused her to suddenly die during consensual intercourse with Cam. Doreen Mantle was asked to travel to England so she could be a witness at Cam's trial. Although she was eager to help, her father talked her out of doing so. But Mike Abel agreed to testify, as did a number of others who had seen Gay's bout of illness. The trial began at the Great Hall of Winchester Castle on March 18, 1948, exactly five months after Gay Gibson had disappeared. By now, the case was a media sensation and had been dubbed the Porthole Murder.
盖伊随后向这位军官解释说，她又发病了。约书亚·卡斯韦尔正在构建一个理论。盖伊·吉布森患有某种心脏病，导致她在与卡姆发生双方自愿的性行为时突然死亡。多琳·曼特尔被要求前往英国，以便在卡姆的审判中作为证人出庭。尽管她很想帮忙，但她的父亲劝阻了她，使她最终没有成行。但迈克·阿贝尔同意出庭作证，其他一些目睹过盖伊发病的人也出庭作证。审判于1948年3月18日在温彻斯特城堡的大厅开始，恰好是在盖伊·吉布森失踪五个月后。此时，这起案件已经轰动了整个媒体，并被冠以“舷窗谋杀案”（The Porthole Murder）的称号。
A murder trial without a body was a highly unusual turn of events, and the case was made even more notorious by the glamorous status of the victim and the scandalous claims being made by the defendant. Hundreds of spectators queued for hours for seats in the gallery. A model of the cabin was constructed to stand in the castle's Great Hall as a prop, complete with a bed and the porthole. The defence presented their argument that Gay Gibson had died accidentally during a consensual sexual encounter. They portrayed Gay as a promiscuous young woman who had possibly been pregnant to a married man. Their expert witnesses included a doctor who told the court that Cam's story was entirely plausible from a medical point of view. The urine and blood on her sheet could have resulted from a natural death,
一场没有尸体的谋杀审判是非常罕见的事件，而由于受害者的迷人身份以及被告提出的耸人听闻的言论，这起案件更具轰动效应。数百名观众在画廊排队数小时以获取座位。城堡的大厅里搭建了一个客舱的模型作为道具，里面配有一张床和一个舷窗。辩护方提出了他们的论点，即盖伊·吉布森在双方自愿的性行为中意外死亡。他们将盖伊描绘成一个放荡的年轻女性，可能怀有某位有妇之夫的孩子。他们的专家证人包括一位告诉法庭卡姆的故事从医学角度来看完全合理的医生。床单上的尿液和血液可能是自然死亡导致的，
and the defendant's description of the way Gay's body stiffened then fell limp, sounded like heart failure, precipitated by lung congestion. A forensic pathologist also agreed with this assessment. He suggested that Gay might have died from an asthma attack, a brain aneurysm, or some kind of heart disease. The fact that people who knew Gay had testified to seeing her faint and turn blue around the mouth suggested she might have had a heart problem. Additionally, the pathologist didn't think the scratches on Cam's body looked like defensive wounds. Cam had no injuries to his hands or thumbs, the locations where a victim would be most likely to scratch someone who was strangling them. The scratches to his forearm looked too high up. James Cam took the stand to share his version of events yet again.
并且被告对盖伊身体僵硬然后瘫软的描述，听起来像是由于肺充血引发的心力衰竭。法医病理学家也同意这种评估。他暗示盖伊可能是死于哮喘发作、脑动脉瘤或某种心脏病。认识盖伊的人曾作证看到她晕倒且嘴唇周围发青的事实，表明她可能患有心脏问题。此外，病理学家认为卡姆身上的抓痕看起来不像是防御性伤口。卡姆的手或拇指没有受伤，而这些恰恰是一个受害者在勒死自己的人时最有可能抓伤的地方。他前臂上的抓痕看起来位置太高了。詹姆斯·卡姆再次走上证人席，分享他的版本的故事。
However, this time he added another detail that he hadn't mentioned before. Gay had been naked beneath her dressing gown. While steadfastly insisting that he had never knowingly harmed Gay, he acknowledged that his snap decision to dispose of her body through the porthole had been beastly conduct. The prosecution presented the court with an entirely different theory. James Cam had killed Gay Gibson after she rejected his advances. During the struggle, she scratched her attacker and pressed the call buttons in her cabin, summoning the night watchman. Terrified his crime would be uncovered, Cam then pushed her either dead or unconscious body through the porthole.
然而，这一次他补充了以前从未提及的另一个细节。盖伊在晨衣里面是赤身裸体的。在坚决坚持自己从未蓄意伤害盖伊的同时，他承认自己冲动决定通过舷窗抛弃尸体是极其野蛮的行为。控方则向法庭提出了截然不同的理论。詹姆斯·卡姆在遭到盖伊的拒绝后杀害了她。在挣扎过程中，她抓伤了袭击者并按下了客舱里的呼叫按钮，唤来了夜间巡逻员。由于害怕罪行败露，卡姆随后将她已经死亡或失去知觉的身体从舷窗推了出去。
The prosecution pointed to the contraceptive devices that had been recovered from Gay's luggage. If she had agreed to have sex with Cam, then why hadn't she made use of these? The fact that Gay's elderly neighbour in the next cabin had heard a crash in the middle of the night suggested there might have been a struggle. And if Gay had died of natural causes, then why hadn't Cam just left her in bed before sneaking out of her room? There would have been no evidence that pointed to him having harmed her, unless her neck was bruised from where Cam had choked her. Gay's mother, Ellen Gibson, was called to give evidence. She denied that her daughter had relationships with married men, saying that her only love was her career. Ellen described Gay as one of the finest types of English womanhood.
控方指出了从盖伊行李中找出的避孕用品。如果她同意与卡姆发生性关系，那么她为什么没有使用这些东西？盖伊隔壁客舱的老邻居在半夜听到了一声巨响，这表明当时可能发生过挣扎。如果盖伊是自然死亡，那么卡姆为什么不在偷偷溜出房间之前把她留在床上？除非她的脖子上有卡姆掐她时留下的瘀伤，否则没有任何证据指向他曾伤害过她。盖伊的母亲埃伦·吉布森被传唤作证。她否认女儿与已婚男士有染，称她唯一的挚爱是自己的事业。埃伦将盖伊描述为英国女性中最优秀的一类人。
She insisted that Charles Shventofsky was never Gay's lover. He was just a business acquaintance who was happy to lend Gay some money to finance her acting ambitions. When Cam's attorney asked, do you know she was telling everybody she was pregnant, Ellen replied, No, my daughter and I were very close friends. We never had any secrets from each other. Although numerous other individuals had claimed they'd seen Gay faint and struggled to breathe on occasion, Ellen said the only health complaint Gay ever had was an ear infection. A renowned pathologist presented a different opinion to the defense experts. He believed the urine on Gay's sheets indicated she had involuntarily wet the bed as she was being choked.
她坚称查尔斯·施文托夫斯基绝不是盖伊的情人。他只是一位商业熟人，很乐意借给盖伊一些钱来资助她的演艺梦想。当卡姆的律师问及“你知道她对所有人说她怀孕了吗”，埃伦回答说：“没有，我和女儿是非常要好的朋友。我们之间没有任何秘密。”尽管许多其他人声称曾看到盖伊偶尔晕厥且呼吸困难，但埃伦表示盖伊唯一的健康问题是耳朵感染。一位著名的病理学家向辩护专家提出了不同的看法。他认为盖伊床单上的尿液表明她在被掐住脖子时不由自主地尿床了。
In his professional experience, loss of bladder control was a symptom typically exhibited by victims of strangulation just before they died. It wasn't seen as often in those who suffered heart failure. When their chance came to cross-examine James Cam, the prosecution wasted no time in challenging each and every one of his claims. They pointed out that he had lied to his fellow crew members and to police for eight days before sharing the story he was now standing by. Instead, fastly denying he had been with Gay on the night in question, Cam couldn't explain why he'd decided to dispose of Gay's body other than to say he had panicked in the moment. He also couldn't answer how the call buttons came to be pushed. Then the prosecution honed in on one key factor in particular, Gay Gibson's missing belongings.
根据他的专业经验，失去膀胱控制通常是扼杀受害者在临死前表现出的症状。在那些突发心脏病的人身上并不常见。当轮到盘问詹姆斯·卡姆时，控方毫不迟疑地对他的每一项供词提出了性质。他们指出，他在分享自己如今坚持的说法之前，曾对船员同仁和警察撒谎长达八天之久。卡姆坚决否认在出事当晚与盖伊在一起，却无法解释除了“当时惊慌失措”之外，他为什么要决定处理掉盖伊的尸体。他也无法回答呼叫按钮是如何被按下的。随后，控方将注意力集中在一个关键因素上，即盖伊·吉布森失踪的随身物品。
Only two items had vanished from Gay's cabin along with her, a pair of black silk pajamas and the yellow quilted dressing gown she wore over the top of them. Cam had made reference to the gown but never mentioned the pajamas. If Gay had been naked under her gown as Cam had only just revealed during his testimony, then where were her pajamas? The prosecution theorised that Gay had been wearing them as per usual but Cam was unaware of this because she fought him off while wearing her gown fully zipped up. He never removed her gown before pushing her through the porthole so he hadn't realised she was wearing anything underneath. Perhaps he'd made the split second decision to tell the court she was naked because it made his story of a planned romantic rendezvous sound more believable. The trial wrapped up within four days and the jury retired to deliberate. Within 45 minutes they had reached a verdict.
盖伊的客舱里只和她一起消失了两件物品：一条黑色的真丝睡衣和她穿在最外面的黄色绗缝晨衣。卡姆提到了晨衣，但从未提及睡衣。如果正如卡姆在作证时刚透露的那样，盖伊在晨衣下面是赤裸的，那么她的睡衣在哪里？控方的理论是，盖伊像往常一样穿着睡衣，但卡姆并不知道这一点，因为她在穿着完全拉上拉链的晨衣时奋力反抗了他。他在把她推出舷窗之前从未脱掉她的晨衣，所以他没有意识到她在里面穿着衣服。也许他做出了在一秒钟内决定告诉法庭她是赤身裸体的决定，因为这使他关于计划中的浪漫约会的说法听起来更可信。审判在四天内结束，陪审团退席商议。在45分钟内，他们便达成了裁决。
James Cam was found guilty of murder. Shocked gasps were heard from the gallery. When Cam was asked if he had anything to say, he replied, I was asked at the start of my trial if I was guilty and I pleaded not guilty. I plead not guilty now. The judge then sentenced him to death by hanging, Britain's compulsory punishment for murder at the time. But within several weeks of his conviction, Cam's fate was thrown into question when the House of Commons passed a motion suspending the death penalty. A new criminal justice bill had been tabled which would see capital punishment abolished if passed into law.
詹姆斯·卡姆被裁定谋杀罪名成立。旁听席上传出了震惊的倒吸气声。当卡姆被问及是否有话要说时，他回答道：“在审判开始时，我被问及是否有罪，我作了无罪抗辩。我现在依然作无罪抗辩。”随后，法官判处他绞刑死刑，这也是当时英国法定的强制性谋杀惩罚。但在他被定罪几周后，随着下议院通过了一项暂停死刑的动议，卡姆的命运变得扑朔迷离。一项新的刑事司法法案已被提交，如果该法案成为法律，死刑将被废除。
In the meantime, all death row prisoners would receive a reprieve. Cam's sentence was commuted to life in prison. Although Cam had been convicted, people continued to speculate as to whether he was guilty or innocent. The case was hotly debated in the media and Gay Gibson's pajamas were regarded as the vital clue that could solve it once and for all. In May 1948, three months after the trial concluded, a 34-year-old man entered a police station in the town of Cheltenham and announced that he had crucial information to share. A week earlier, the man had been sitting in a pub when he struck up a conversation with a young researcher for the BBC named John Langham. The two chatted about the government's recent moratorium on the death penalty and soon the subject of Gay Gibson and James Cam arose. John Langham informed the man that he knew Gay hadn't been wearing the pajamas when she died because they were currently in the possession of his dentist.
在此期间，所有死囚都将获得缓刑。卡姆的刑期被减为无期徒刑。尽管卡姆已被定罪，人们仍在猜测他究竟是有罪还是无罪。这起案件在媒体上引起了激烈的争论，而盖伊·吉布森的睡衣则被视为能够一劳永逸解开谜团的关键线索。1948年5月，即审判结束三个月后，一名34岁的男子走进切尔滕纳姆镇的一个警察局，宣布他有重要情报要分享。一周前，这名男子正坐在一家酒吧里，与一名名叫约翰·兰厄姆的年轻BBC研究员攀谈起来。两人聊起了政府最近对死刑的暂停令，不久便谈到了盖伊·吉布森和詹姆斯·卡姆的话题。约翰·兰厄姆告诉这名男子，他知道盖伊死时并没有穿那套睡衣，因为睡衣目前在他的牙医手里。
During a dental appointment, the dentist told Langham how he had been on the same voyage as Gay and occupied the cabin next door to her. The two had become friendly and Gay paid him a visit the night before her death. They had sex and she left her black pajamas behind by accident. To prove his story, the dentist showed Langham the pajamas but refused to go public saying that he feared what that would do to his business and personal life. The man told the police he didn't know the dentist's name or address but suggested they obtained them from Langham. A detective took down his statement but thought little of it. This individual was already known to them and although he could carry on a decent conversation, he was believed to have, quote, some slight mental disorder. His story wasn't taken too seriously although John Langham was indeed a researcher at the BBC.
在一次牙科预约中，牙医告诉兰厄姆，他曾与盖伊搭乘同一艘船，并且就住在她隔壁的客舱。两人成为了朋友，盖伊在死前的那天晚上还拜访了他。他们发生了性关系，而她不小心留下了黑色睡衣。为了证明自己的说法，牙医向兰厄姆展示了睡衣，但拒绝公开，称他担心这会对他的商业和个人生活造成什么影响。这名男子告诉警方，他不知道牙医的名字或地址，但建议他们从兰厄姆那里获取。一名警探记录了他的供词，但并没有太放在心上。此人早已为他们所知，尽管他能进行正常的交谈，但人们认为他“有一些轻微的精神障碍”。他的故事没有被太严肃地对待，尽管约翰·兰厄姆确实是BBC的一名研究人员。
In the years that followed, he became a well-known presenter for the broadcaster. In 1965, he took his own life at the age of 40. More recently, crime writer Anthony Brown began digging into the Gay Gibson case and decided to investigate the man's story. Through examining passenger records, he discovered that there was, in fact, a 43-year-old dental surgeon travelling alone on the Durban Castle at the same time as Gay Gibson. The man's cabin number wasn't available but Brown concluded it was unlikely he occupied the one next door to Gay as her only known neighbour was an elderly woman. Moreover, if Gay had left her pyjamas in another passenger's cabin, then stewardess Eileen Field would have noticed them missing a day earlier. If a dentist that did indeed claim to have slept with Gay and kept her pyjamas, then it seems probable that he made the story up. Not long after his conviction, James Camm filed an appeal and lost. It was only then that some new information came to light.
在接下来的几年里，他成为了这家广播公司知名的主持人。1965年，他在40岁时结束了自己的生命。最近，犯罪小说作家安东尼·布朗开始深入挖掘盖伊·吉布森案，并决定调查这个男人的故事。通过检查乘客记录，他发现确实有一位43岁的牙科外科医生在盖伊·吉布森同一时期独自乘坐“德班城堡号”。该男子的客舱号无法查到，但布朗推断他不太可能住在盖伊隔壁，因为她唯一已知的邻居是一位老妇人。此外，如果盖伊把睡衣落在了其他乘客的客舱里，那么乘务员艾琳·菲尔德会在一天前就注意到它们不见了。如果真有一个牙医声称与盖伊睡过并保留了她的睡衣，那么这个故事很可能是他捏造的。定罪后不久，詹姆斯·卡姆提出上诉但遭驳回。直到那时，一些新信息才浮出水面。
Camm had always been viewed by his fellow crewmates as a ladies man who saw no problem with cheating on his wife. In reality, he was a sexual predator. In September 1947, Alice, not her real name, set sail on the Durban Castle. Alice was a young nanny who was travelling to South Africa with her employer. During the voyage, she became friendly with dexterity James Camm. One day, the two arranged to meet on the ship's promenade deck. When Alice arrived, Camm directed her towards a storage cabin as he followed behind, carrying two drinks. They stepped inside the cabin and Camm locked the door behind them.
卡姆在船员同仁眼中一直是个风流成性、觉得背叛妻子理所当然的花花公子。实际上，他是一个性掠夺者。1947年9月，化名爱丽丝的女子登上了“德班城堡号”。爱丽丝是一位年轻的保姆，正随雇主前往南非。航行期间，她与水手詹姆斯·卡姆熟络起来。一天，两人约定在船上的散步甲板见面。爱丽丝到达后，卡姆领着她走向一间储藏舱，自己则端着两餐饮品跟在后面。他们走进舱内，卡姆随手将门反锁。
The pair sat side by side on deck chairs and chatted for a little while. Suddenly, Camm was looming over Alice. He said that he wanted to kiss her. Alice refused, then told Camm she had to go. He demanded a kiss before she left, but Alice declined again. The next thing she knew, she was kneeling on the floor. The back of her neck was pressed against the deck chair she'd been sitting in moments earlier, and her head was being pushed down on its seat. Camm was kneeling next to her, one hand clasping the back of her neck, the other gripping her throat. He was strangling her.
两人并肩坐在沙滩椅上聊了一会儿。突然，卡姆居高临下地逼近爱丽丝。他说他想吻她。爱丽丝拒绝了，并告诉卡姆她必须离开。在她离开前，他索要一个吻，但爱丽丝再次拒绝。等她回过神来时，她已经跪在地上了。她的后颈被紧紧压在她几分钟前坐过的沙滩椅上，头部也被往下按在座位上。卡姆跪在她身旁，一只手掐着她的后颈，另一只手死死扼住她的喉咙。他在掐她。
Time seemed to rush by as Alice struggled to comprehend what was happening. Eventually, Camm stopped and let her go. Alice was destroyed. Her mouth was bleeding and she could see her own blood smeared on the white collar of Camm's uniform. His face was drenched in sweat. He apologized and said he couldn't understand what came over him, but he hoped she would stay quiet, for her sake, as well as his own. Alice raced back to her cabin. When she looked in the mirror, she saw that her eyes were bloodshot and her face had turned purple.
在爱丽丝极力理解究竟发生了什么的过程中，时间仿佛飞逝。最终，卡姆停下来放开了她。爱丽丝崩溃了。她的嘴在流血，她能看到自己的血涂抹在卡姆制服的白色领子上。他的汗水湿透了脸。他道了歉，说自己不明白当时怎么会做出那种举动，但他希望她能为了她自己也为了他保守秘密。爱丽丝跑回了自己的客舱。当她照镜子时，发现自己的眼睛布满血丝，脸也变成了紫色。
She confided in a friend about the attack before going to see the ship's doctor several days later. Her eyes remained red and bruised for some time. When she later showed Camm what he had done to her, he remarked, Good God, I did not think your eyes would come up like that. Four days after this attack, Brianna, not her real name, decided to have a nap one afternoon. Like Alice, Brianna was a passenger on the Durban Castle and aged in her late teens. She was travelling with her aunt, but staying in her own private cabin. At about 2.30pm, she went to her room and shut the door without locking it, then fell asleep on her bed.
她在几天后去看船医之前，向一位朋友倾诉了这次袭击。她的眼睛红肿淤青持续了一段时间。当她后来向卡姆展示他对她做过的事时，他评论道：“天哪，我没想到你的眼睛会肿成这样。”这次袭击发生四天后，化名布里安娜的女子决定在一天下午小睡一会儿。和爱丽丝一样，布里安娜也是“德班城堡号”上的乘客，年方十几岁。她与姑姑同行，但住在自己的私人客舱里。大约下午2点30分，她走进房间，在没有反锁的情况下关上门，然后在床上睡着了。
It wasn't long before something suddenly woke her. James Camm was kneeling beside her. Brianna recognized him. Despite being a crew member, he had always been very forward and overly familiar, referring to her by her first name. Frightened, Brianna quickly moved to get up. Camm pushed her back down onto the bed. Then he lay down on top of her, pressing his weight against her. Brianna struggled, but he was too heavy. Camm grabbed her shoulders and began to kiss her. He grabbed her chest and tried to remove some straps that were keeping her shorts on.
没过多久，某种动静突然将她惊醒。詹姆斯·卡姆正跪在她身旁。布里安娜认出了他。尽管是一名船员，他却一直表现得非常轻浮和过分熟络，直呼她的名字。布里安娜感到害怕，急忙起身。卡姆把她重新按回床上。接着，他压在她身上，将全身的重量施加在她身上。布里安娜奋力挣扎，但他太重了。卡姆抓住她的肩膀开始亲吻她。他抓住她的胸部，试图解开固定她短裤的一些带子。
Eventually, Brianna succeeded in pushing him off her. She told him her aunt was in the very next cabin, then knocked on the wall. This appeared to unsettle Camm. He stood and said he would fetch her some tea, then left. Brianna was humiliated by the attack. She told a male friend and the assistant Persa, but decided not to take it further. Approximately two weeks later, another adolescent was assaulted by Camm on board the Durban Castle. On the evening of October 6th, Christine, not her real name, attended a dinner dance. As she was dancing with an officer, Camm approached and told the officer that the band wanted to pack up for the night. Christine and the officer parted ways, with Christine going to her cabin.
最终，布里安娜成功将他推开。她告诉他姑姑就在隔壁客舱，然后敲了敲墙壁。这似乎让卡姆感到不安。他站起身说要去给她泡茶，然后离开了。布里安娜对这次袭击感到受到羞辱。她把此事告诉了一位男性朋友和助理事务长，但决定不再追究。大约两周后，另一名未成年人也在“德班城堡号”上遭到卡姆的袭击。10月6日晚，化名克里斯蒂娜的女子参加了一场晚宴舞会。正当她与一名军官跳舞时，卡姆走过来告诉军官乐队准备收工了。克里斯蒂娜和军官分开了，克里斯蒂娜回到了自己的客舱。
She fell asleep, only to wake up about an hour later at 12.30am. Camm was standing by her bed. He apologized for stopping the dance, explaining that officers were not permitted to dance with passengers. Christine retorted that he wasn't allowed in her cabin either. Camm just laughed and sat on her bed. Then he put his arms around Christine and kissed her, ignoring her protests. She managed to pull away and turned from him, burying her face in a pillow. She was too scared to scream. Camm sat in silence for several minutes before he got up and left. 12 days later, Gay Gibson went missing. After Camm's arrest, all three women filed affidavits with South African police, who passed them on to their counterparts in Southampton.
她睡着了，但在大约一个小时后（即凌晨12点30分）醒来。卡姆正站在她的床边。他为打断舞蹈道歉，解释说军官不允许与乘客跳舞。克里斯蒂娜反驳说，他同样不被允许进入她的客舱。卡姆只是笑笑，坐在她的床沿上。然后他搂住克里斯蒂娜并亲吻她，无视她的抗争。她设法挣脱并转过身，把脸埋进枕头里。她吓得不敢尖叫。卡姆默默地坐了几分钟，然后起身离开了。12天后，盖伊·吉布森失踪了。卡姆被捕后，这三名女性都向南非警方提交了宣誓书，南非警方随即将这些文件转交给了南安普顿的同行。
However, these incidents were not raised during Camm's trial, as they were considered prejudicial. They only became public knowledge when a newspaper published a story about them after Camm's appeal was quashed. During his time behind bars, Camm was considered a model prisoner. He never caused any problems for the prison staff, and after serving just 11 years of his sentence, it was decided he should be released on license. Camm left Wakefield Prison in September 1959. By this time, he was 42 years old and his wife had divorced him. A few weeks later, he shared his story with the Sunday pictorial newspaper. An article written in the first person told his version of events on the night that Gay died. Just as he had for years, Camm described a consensual sexual encounter followed by Gay's sudden and unexpected death.
然而，这些事件在卡姆受审期间并未被提及，因为它们被认为具有预审偏见。直到一家报纸在卡姆的上诉被驳回后发表了一篇关于这些事件的报道，它们才大白于天下。在狱中服刑期间，卡姆被视为模范囚犯。他从未给监狱工作人员带来任何麻烦，在服刑仅11年后，当局决定对其实施假释。卡姆于1959年9月离开韦克菲尔德监狱。当时他42岁，妻子已经与他离婚。几周后，他向《星期日画报》讲述了自己的故事。一篇以第一人称撰写的文章讲述了他在盖伊去世当晚的经历。正如多年来所做的那样，卡姆描述了一次你情我愿的性接触，随后是盖伊突然而不幸的死亡。
But this time, he added a few details he'd never mentioned before. He claimed that Gay had scratched his arms during sex and said he had accidentally knocked the cavern's call buttons when turning on the overhead light. Author Anthony Brown has noted that the switch for this light was not located anywhere near the call buttons. Camm also claimed that Gay had arched her back during her apparent heart failure, a detail he never mentioned before, but which echoed testimony provided by an officer who had witnessed a spasm Gay experienced while in the armed forces. The article concluded with Camm's graphic description of how he had squeezed Gay's body through the cavern's small porthole. The Sunday pictorial paid Camm £2,500 for his story, the equivalent of £50,000 or $91,000 in today's money. Camm changed his name to James Clark and got work as a head waiter.
但这一次，他补充了一些以前从未提及的细节。他声称盖伊在性爱时抓伤了他的手臂，并说自己在打开顶灯时无意中撞到了客舱的呼叫按钮。作家安东尼·布朗指出，这盏灯的开关根本不在呼叫按钮附近。卡姆还声称盖伊在疑似心脏病发作时曾弓起背部，这是他以前从未提过的细节，但却与一名目睹盖伊在军队服役期间经历痉挛的军官提供的证词相呼应。文章最后是卡姆生动的描述，讲述他是如何将盖伊的身体塞进客舱狭小的舷窗里的。《星期日画报》向卡姆支付了2500英镑的稿酬，相当于当今的5万英镑或9.1万美元。卡姆将名字改为詹姆斯·克拉克，并找到了一份领班侍应的工作。
Some time later, he sexually assaulted a 13-year-old girl. Despite being convicted of this crime, he was only given two years probation. After this period was up, he relocated to Scotland and began working at a hotel. One night in 1971, he broke into a room where three 11-year-old girls were staying. The trio were travelling as part of a school trip. The incident led to Camm being charged with sexual misbehaviour and he was sent back to prison. He was released yet again in 1978, only to die one year later at the age of 62. Gay Gibson's death at sea has inspired novels and even a radio series.
一段时间后，他性侵了一名13岁女孩。尽管此罪名成立，他却只被判处两年缓刑。缓刑期满后，他搬到苏格兰并在一家酒店工作。1971年的一天晚上，他闯入了一个房间，里面住着三个11岁的小女孩。这三人是参加学校旅行的成员。这起事件导致卡姆被控性骚扰并被送回监狱。他于1978年再次获释，却在一年后以62岁的高龄去世。盖伊·吉布森在海上遇害一事启发了多部小说甚至广播剧。
Over the years, numerous authors and legal experts have debated Camm's guilt or innocence. In 2018, crime writer Anthony Brown examined the story as part of a cold case series he has published. He gained access to the case's full and original police files through the Hampshire Constabulary History Society, which allowed him to write the most detailed account of gay's death to date. His book, titled Death of an Actress, reproduced official documents verbatim and shared new details that had been missed in earlier investigations. Brown doesn't believe that gay was murdered, nor does he believe she consented to sex with Camm and died of natural causes. His theory is that Camm assaulted gay and accidentally killed her.
多年来，众多作家和法律专家一直在争论卡姆是有罪还是无罪。2018年，犯罪作家安东尼·布朗在他出版的一系列冷案纪实中探讨了这个故事。他通过汉普郡警察历史协会获得了该案完整且原始的警察档案，这使他能够撰写迄今为止关于盖伊之死最详细的叙述。他的书名为《一个女演员之死》，逐字复制了官方文件，并分享了早期调查中遗漏的新细节。布朗不相信盖伊是被谋杀的，也不相信她同意与卡姆发生性关系并死于自然原因。他的理论是卡姆袭击了盖伊并意外杀害了她。
Camm had been attacking teenage girls regularly in the lead-up to gay's death and choked at least one other victim. Camm always attacked his other victims when they were fully clothed, making it entirely plausible that he didn't remove gay's dressing gown and never realised she was wearing pajamas underneath. During the attack, gay pressed the call buttons, which went unnoticed by Camm. Brown has speculated that the small, cat-like scratches on Camm's neck may have been caused by gay defending herself with her hairbrush and scraping him with the bristles. The lack of defensive wounds on Camm's hands indicates to Brown
在盖伊遇害前夕，卡姆一直有规律地袭击十几岁的女孩，并且至少掐死过另一名受害者。卡姆在袭击其他受害者时总是穿着衣服，这完全有可能说明他当时没有脱掉盖伊的晨衣，也根本没有意识到她里面穿着睡衣。在袭击过程中，盖伊按下了呼叫按钮，而卡姆并没有注意到。布朗推测，卡姆脖子上猫抓般的小伤痕可能是盖伊用发刷自卫并用刷毛抓伤他造成的。卡姆手上没有防御性伤口，这让布朗认为
that he may have inadvertently killed gay during an assault rather than strangled her. His heavy weight bearing down on gay exacerbated her breathing problems in a cabin that was already humid due to the tropical climate. Brown believes gay was suffering from some kind of heart disease, as suggested by those who had seen her fall ill on multiple occasions. He hoped the question of her health would be answered once and for all by DNA evidence, as some strands of gay's hair remained intact on her hairbrush even decades later. But experts have advised that due to the age and scarcity of the hair samples,
他可能是在袭击过程中无意中害死了盖伊，而不是蓄意将其勒死。由于客舱本就因热带气候而闷热潮湿，卡姆压在盖伊身上的沉重体重加剧了她的呼吸困难。正如那些曾多次目睹她发病的人所暗示的那样，布朗相信盖伊当时患有某种心脏病。他希望通过DNA证据一劳永逸地解答她的健康状况问题，因为几十年来，盖伊的一些头发仍然完好地保留在她的发刷上。但专家建议，由于头发样本的年代久远且数量稀少，
such testing shouldn't be undertaken until there are further advancements in DNA technology. When Camm was arrested, he asked police officers, does this mean I murdered her? And later remarked, my God, I didn't think it would be as serious as this. Brown points to these odd remarks as further evidence that Camm may have unintentionally killed gay. Five days before she died, Eileen Gay Gibson penned a letter to her parents back in South Africa. In it, she detailed her plans for when the ship docked in Southampton. She had already investigated which train to catch in order to reach London
在DNA技术取得进一步进展之前，不应进行此类检测。当卡姆被捕时，他问警官：“这是否意味着我谋杀了她？”后来又感叹：“天哪，我没想到事情会这么严重。”布朗指出这些奇怪的言论进一步证明卡姆可能是无意中杀害了盖伊。在去世前五天，艾琳·盖伊·吉布森给远在南非的父母写了一封信。信中，她详细描述了船靠岸南安普顿后的计划。她已经查好了要搭乘哪趟火车才能到达伦敦
and contacted a hotel to request accommodation. Once settled, she would begin the next exciting chapter of her life by connecting with various theatres and acting agents. Gay noted how few passengers there were on the voyage, describing the Durban Castle as a ghost ship. But overall, she was having a pleasant time. She spent her days dozing, either in a deck chair in the sun or in her private cabin. The fellow passengers she was dining with were kind to her,
并联系了一家酒店预订房间。一旦安顿下来，她将通过联系各大剧院和演艺经纪人，开启她人生中激动人心的新篇章。盖伊注意到航程中的乘客寥寥无几，把“德班城堡号”形容为一艘幽灵船。但总体而言，她过得很愉快。她把时间都花在打盹上，要么在阳光下的沙滩椅上，要么在她的私人客舱里。与她共进晚餐的同船乘客对她很好，
and she was very well looked after by the cabin crew. Overall, it was a lovely journey. The only thing she was missing were her parents. Signing off, Eileen Gay Gibson wrote the words, Wish you could share this comfort with me. You're loving, Eileen. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且客舱船员对她照顾得无微不至。总的来说，这是一段美妙的旅程。她唯一怀念的就是父母。在信尾，艾琳·盖伊·吉布森写道：“真希望你能与我分享这份舒适。爱你的，艾琳。”目前本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。